refreshing on here you tell me when
someone comes in all right I'll keep an
eye on the door there's no internet
connection you're live we're building an
audience for you I like watch these guys
yeah just suck these guys out Mark
Zuckerberg his cousin to be like just
knocking on doors tune in to this
channel right now oh yeah that's all
right if we build it they will come if
we build it they will come yeah just
like in that movie mmm XXX Bull Durham
hey guys hey eloy Garcia you Lloyd
Garcia I arrive once more Alexander
Hawes hey buddy just pulling it up here
welcome what do i do too likes to see it
your singing click to enlarge all right
here if you want to go to its own thing
yeah you can go up a little more and
click the publish by or is it click the
just now and then I'll take you do its
own page buggins logans that's the most
that will be the most up to snuff you
turn your radio down hey guys as your
Martinez we are drinking samuel adams
sent 20 pounds of pumpkin guts the fall
time and i'm not you p so we're just
waiting for a few more people to arrive
but we'll let you guys know now thank
you that we will end this at 952 955
p.m. yes we're not going to do in our
time is 930 p.m. john is very hungry and
grumpy he's like walter matthau and
grumpy old men the old grumpy guy yeah
um anyway uh yeah we're gonna have some
movie talk about something to talk about
some films some movie news multitasking
here watching the flash and you
gentlemen whoa whoa whoa put the flash
down put the flash down you can binge
watch the flash this [ __ ] is why
[ __ ] is live this is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity that
helped her probably later on in the week
or next week yeah you better get your
attention you know the words because
we're ready we're ready to go all right
preps um have them there's so much for
people you think our fans is all watch
up there 10 at least there's ten nine
why are not more people chiming in we're
not going to have this movie talk
alrighty low i fine i guess i'll forgive
you you can read the flash it's all
right you see if we did this on youtube
there'd be thousands of people we do
this on facebook because we're trying to
keep it exclusive yeah for you just for
you brianna you specifically eloy garcia
and andrew martinez yeah man he didn't
even answer a question and alexander
hall is too awesome loves ya Alexander
how's that shower can wait my for a hand
out saying I've been showering without
five days straight lately and I look
great look at me look at me I look fresh
I smell good know my [ __ ] still smell
all right I'm telling you man I know
what it's like to not shower for a while
and sometimes ladies like it Timmy
Miller for the Flash movie state of your
anus if it makes your [ __ ] smell worse
Christine that girl I would assume it's
always nice to have a female sub you're
part of the ten percent demographic of
our YouTube channel oh sorry are you on
a computer now I hope so well um all
right I guess we'll kick off this movie
talking let's just get into it with you
guys you guys starting small starting
fresh let's do this let's kick um so
there's a few specific ones we wanted to
cover that's right John wick a director
or two well not nap no no what about
John chapter two oh no that's right
we're not talking about that we talking
about Deadpool to and how they want to
get the director of cha hey Julian Jones
who they want oh wow people are subtly
tuning in Logan burns hello to new
zealand yeah that's where they film the
Great Hobbit films I love those movies
as much or as equal to how I love
of the Rings yes yes okay so Deadpool to
they want to get the director John wick
for this now for my understanding this
guy has only done John wick in John wick
to I don't know of other films he's done
I know he was more involved like visual
effects before okay yeah and then that
then is that Tim that was Tim Miller's
deal too right yes yes it was Tim Miller
was involved with visual effects but
before and he has a visual effects
company which allowed him to do Deadpool
tagine I have a laptop here to make sure
i get some facts right here cuz God
knows I don't know anything you know a
lot of thing that's not true show them
you don't need a butter me up I always
seek to butter you up John wick three
John Lawson knows facts you did a lot of
stunts no he's a stuntman I got that I
wrong that's right he did stunt work and
a lot of fight scene choreography and
that's how Keanu Reeves sought him out
to actually direct John wick because he
worked a lot on the fight scenes and
stuff I remember that now dressed and
what so so it's just like he's only
directed John wick and the
post-production phase of John wick
chapter teeth man so it's interesting to
see how you know they're going after
another guy who is not the most popular
director it's an interesting choice
though granted what did you know what
Tim Miller did before Deadpool no I why
I know he did a lot of effects work I
don't know wasn't this his big
directorial debut I believe so uh cuz
this that's um the thing about that is
um uh I forgot my train of thought keep
going wow great livestream we're having
here way to go thank you um no um what's
interesting to me about because John
wick in Deadpool are kind of similar in
some aspects of Stoops no no no no no
like I'm I
I only slept for like cameras my brain
is skipping John wick and Deadpool are
kind of similar in terms of how they got
me because John wick is wasn't like a
highly like there was blacklisted for
several years yes script that a lot of
people really really wanted to get done
but no one was interested in making it
so Keanu Reeves came around and it was
really interested in the project and got
attached and they made the film for I
think the budget was only like 40
million dollars and they truly tuned out
this wonderful action film and Deadpool
you know small film only 50 million
dollar budget and they turned out a
great film and I from my understanding
at least the rumors report is that Tim
Miller and Ryan Reynolds they were
disputing a lot of differences on the
fact that he wanted to go bigger make it
a crazier kind of action film really go
all out with a comic book exploration
all that stuff and he had preference
over who cable would be and I guess that
wasn't who Ryan Reynolds yeah so I feel
like in the same way how John wick
that's a lot of Keanu Reeves is
controlling on the film as well yeah I
feel like Ryan Reynolds will have more
of the control on this film that any
writer or director who comes on board
for this movie it seems like Ryan
Reynolds is the power powers that
because this was the whole thing reigned
over like you can replace the director
you could replace the writer you can't
replace Ryan Reynolds though that's just
the thing yeah you can't replace Ryan
rounds I don't know anyone else I could
do Deadpool yeah and I'm kind of sad to
see this team split apart cuz I thought
Tim Miller did a really good job with
Deadpool I'd be curious to see what what
is the John wick character's name um
chance the hell skier chads2 hells yeah
i mean i'm curious to see what he would
do with a Deadpool the thing is like
John wick has such a distinct style that
I can't see it yet like I know the
action would be cool well you see that
no but that's the thing though is that
Deadpool have good action but nothing
that really stood out as really
memorable action sequences we walk away
from Deadpool in terms of how funny it
was how fun it was and everything John
wait a story motivation yeah but i feel
like the main thing audience general
audiences took away
from it was how funny the film was how
entertaining it was but there's no real
defining action sequences where I feel
like he jumped the director John wick
can really provide that I think you'd be
a great director for that he knows how
to work on and keep it on a smaller
budget keeping in a more personal story
and he has so much experience with cool
stunts and stuff my concern is will he
get the tone down in a good way that's
what I'm saying he has to do the same
tone but John wick is a very serious
movie well that's that's what I mean
it's like John wick is like everything
is very picturesque and there are a lot
of long takes and it is a very intense
like like there are moments of levity
but it's a it's an intense dark gritty
movie and it's very straightforward and
Deadpool is a lot of different tones and
a different look you know it's like I
just don't know anything about this
guy's range so you know which is cool on
the one hand it's exciting it's like oh
ok this is this is a big opportunity for
this guy to maybe do something else
really cool it's authored by him you
know and then immediately have something
to jump out on so he doesn't just be the
John wick guy forever yeah but you know
I want to know what that looks like and
I'm I honestly feel like could be able
to create a good middle ground between
what Tim Miller wanted and what Ryan
Reynolds still wants to continue with us
well if they choose him I got imagine
like Ryan Reynolds and him have clearly
agreed and I've learned to trust
Reynolds about this so like I'm a little
weary on on this situation but it seems
like he hasn't given me a reason to not
trust him yet I just feel like the what
like one thing about Deadpool when I
heard all this top dispute between Tim
Miller is George Miller what somebody
somebody said didn't Tim Miller direct
madman he hopes you're here by doing
that well no it's like I Jordan comment
long everybody else that it's not for
everybody it's like oh hey you know oh
there's a reason uh Laurie talking about
we were talking about Deadpool to and
Ryan Reynolds and his yeah judgment well
the the biggest dispute that I when I
was hearing about it was how you know
Tim Miller really didn't want to go a
lot bigger and crazier in terms of
visual effects but let's look at this
from a perspective like Batman V
Superman pose
the coolest scene had a batman v
superman was when bad man [ __ ] kicked
ass on his own in a cool martial arts
fight scene and when you look at the
action sequences in John wick they're
done on a good budget they're not it
looks real it a very stylistic but
there's a sense of brutality and we
listened to it I love it and I feel like
Deadpool could use an amp up out of
anything Deadpool can amp up its the
choreography and cooler action sequences
not necessarily bigger not necessarily
huge crazy spectacle but the guy has
swords and guns you know well yeah I
feel like bigger is not necessarily the
direction you want to go with Deadpool
because the charm part of the charm of
the first movie part of what separated
it from all the other superhero movies
at the time was that it wasn't
destroying like half the country with
giant set pieces it was like a very
personal story yeah and it was it felt
like you know a city like a little world
and John wick has that same feeling word
you know the world doesn't feel so huge
that you can't relate to it anymore yeah
so that does seem like a good match you
know in that regard and eloy Garcia says
John wick also made you feel for the
character and I feel like Tim Miller did
get you to feel for the character but i
think one thing that overall a lot of
people can agree on i mean i think in
terms of general audiences like for me I
really loved Eppel the first time I saw
it the second time I saw it I still
loved it it was oh it was the dramatic
scenes that I felt kind of lingered a
little too long that was the only part
of it and that and I feel like that's
what that is where my concern comes in
because I feel like he could give great
dramatic scenes but then it might be too
dramatic yeah for the drama and John
wick is shot very well yeah it is and
that's again that's just another thing
I'm curious to see about this
collaboration because it seems like
whoever directs this is going to have to
collaborate with ryne rooms yeah I make
this you know move in and you know have
to collaborate with the writers i'm sure
those four people together kind of the
main you know circulation chamber that
all these ideas come out of so you know
it seems like it's kind of always going
to be Ryan rounds vision
anyway yeah with some pepper brought in
by yeah but you know whoever's directing
but it seems like a good combo yeah well
that's we're moving on to the next story
now I still keep hoping the soska twins
will get a good day probably I don't
know um oh oh the flash sure you all
have heard about this oh no oh that's
right the same time that around the same
time when Tim Miller leaves Deadpool to
Rick humbly one family wha leaves the
flash which is um I sort of not
surprising as no surprise with all the
horrible like within WB employee
speaking out against DC Cinematic
Universe and and with every every you
know but he just kind of trashing on the
films lately and worried about the
process and how marketing is misleading
and how marketing is the daily they're
they're really the poster child for that
right now because like all these all
their movies seem to rely on this is why
I'm so weary of the the Justice League
trailer cuz I'm like I know how cool
this looks and I know that you know I
know but what is the actual movie gonna
be yeah I mean cuz he did something I
didn't see all of dope but I saw a good
amount of trailers and a lot of life
Oakland sauce a lot of clips and it was
interesting hearing that are we gonna
get this guy to do the flash because I
was like that could be different but
then knowing DC though yeah they offer
I'm like how did I will they allow this
to be do the openers are gonna freak out
and recut the movie and then release an
extended edition later anyway so just
yeah how much does a does director get
to do on one of these movie I mean I I
guess the big question is like who would
you want to wreck the flash then and I
feel like obvious choice would be to try
to get Phil Lord and Chris Miller Beck
well yes other names yeah alright yeah I
think that would be like the great like
to try to get them back yeah I feel like
that's I don't know why this was like
conflict with doing a Star Wars film or
something I'm not sure why they left I
always dzi just guys are
member why they live but yeah I mean I
feel like that if James Wan stuck
through all of Aquaman without really
hear us hearing about horrible things
going on behind the scenes or something
I feel like James Wan if he's the kind
of guy who I feel I can still be
creative under studio you know heads
like keeping an eye on him yeah and I
saw and hey James Wan has very unique
style and touches and he did get like he
pearly fast and library with them I know
we didn't finish for yourself when I was
showing it to you we just weren't in the
mood to watch it but when we when you
watch furious 7 as the film keeps going
it gets more the genes want Flair and he
shows like through a lot of it that he
can still honor the Fast and Furious
Flair but provide his own and I feel
like if they were allowing James want to
do that they would allow another
director to kind of do that with the
flash and I feel like the flash needs
that my concern is that the flash TV
show is like the best thing DC currently
has going on that is it's so that and
then Superman on Supergirl is going well
and arrows kind of like up in the air
about how people feel about it so yeah
but when it comes to the flash TV show
being so well I really hope they'd go
out of their way to make it feel very
different than the show to not try to go
people love the show so we gotta make it
kind of like that like no you're gonna
confuse your audience's if you do that
and I'd like to hear phil lord chris
miller not doing it has always been kind
of a bummer to me cuz I'm like these are
the perfect one it's like Edgar Wright
not doing a man yeah like it's a girl I
would make a cool flash movie he would
make we had to play like dream director
on this i would think edgar i would be
the best one for the job somebody
pitched him to me for Deadpool as well
and I would be afraid for that version
but it would be cool like it could work
yeah and he can he's the guy who can do
cool [ __ ] on a budget you know yeah yeah
exactly but yeah it would be really nice
to have filler to Chris Miller Beck but
I do I don't see it happening at all mm
I just don't I feel like they I feel
like when they left they probably
you know and the engine see this Gatley
like i was i was really excited for rick
from you but at the same time it just
doesn't seem like the place like just
what i know about dope in a lot stuff I
feel like Edgar Wright will be a perfect
choice because if you look at the the
cycle of directors they've been going
through filler and chris miller Rick
femi you uh huh me you what yeah just
sounded them fam ooh ye Hwa [ __ ] family
wha Rick fam ooh wha-bam oooh yeeaah
horrible learning to speak I'm finally
on the season 5 finale oh nice yeah Rick
just went crazy and beat that dude oh
yeah nuts and then the other guy was new
behind Glen yeah I'm really behind
everyone's getting beat up hi guys I've
Vladimir I've Vladimir you know who else
join in on the conversation that we
missed out on Christopher no longer
flash messing with timelines I don't Oh
Christopher Nolan's flash would be
strange and interesting I mean like he's
already done as superhero movie so I
guess I could see it because of that
true true true it's really weird
watching his Hannah what's up um okay uh
yeah well right yeah I think it was my
drink flag I get a little bit Spacey
right would be awesome at the flash I
feel like he's the other he's the other
one um and they want to include cyborg
in the film or of course they do because
why make the film you're making but I at
the same time though I think that's not
a bad idea it's probably not a bad idea
in fact you know I because we don't know
a lot about cyborgs i think it is smart
to introduce him in one of the other
movies so that we go oh yeah I want to
learn about this yeah I and then we'll
see an orange it's kind of like what
they did with black panther and civil
war like she stood out well you know jon
is one of two Americans that have not
seen the captain america so cold yup so
it's a small company but hey we get
along dr. strange coming out I'm excited
for dr. I'm really excited for Dutch
I'm using civil war I know I like I
don't know like I want to see you
convinced me to like actually really
want to see it so so yeah I regret
already not having seen in theaters like
John wick but before I saw Dickens like
yeah i know i should have Tommy leg
drinking e you [ __ ] you drinking
Tommy it's only fair to cyborg since
they took a stand so wait there is no
cyber or standalone movie or are they
going to I don't think there's a cyborg
standalone movie in the works right now
oh because I think they wanted to make
room for a Batman solo film damn and no
one really knows you sigh worship take
your time do you see like stop it we got
to Sylvester Stallone news you want to
cover in the next 10 minutes this escape
plan to escape plan to oh wait I I can't
ignore that question we wanted to add my
955 oh sorry we can do it boom boom boom
biz margarine such a DC try again with a
Green Lantern movie only this time using
the jon stewart character well i don't
think you need to replace some of the
host of the daily ship Oh be very
informative move it probably wouldn't be
the green legend man before you know you
can Lobby movie you know what I talk
about Donald Trump like in the actual
comic book uh uh okay yeah well yes I
don't do I don't think they need to just
replace him with jon stewart I mean
that'd be cool to get that character in
there but Hal Jordan is such a big part
of their like I'm not the biggest DC
enthusiast but here's what I do know Hal
Jordan is such a huge part of the DC
lower in the DC Universe that he
deserves to have it done right he
deserves to have a like yeah you guys
messed up with one movie about him well
let's give it another shot it's give
another Hal Jordan and I feel like
there's other actors who could play him
and I I feel like they should give the
Green Lantern another shop but they
should make it an event ya feel like
they should do this when they figure
themselves out and they've had a couple
good movies under their belt so that a
you know Ryan Reynolds kind of brought
it
back up with Deadpool and especially
like riffing it in the trailer like you
know yeah the bad association of green
lantern is still there so I feel like
they should definitely do it but I feel
like they should do it after they've
already had some success and after they
have enough stability to just be able to
really [ __ ] make green absolutely you
know because it seems like right now
they're good at fumbling event movies
like things that should be like Batman
shouldn't come after bvs it's just not
how that should work out and so once
they've got that figured out I feel like
yes let's definitely do Green Lantern
again because that character deserves
it's like we can forgive them in a
Superman cuz we've already gotten good
versions but it's harder to forgive the
Green Lantern because you [ __ ] it up
out the gate yeah so see ya definitely
just when it's time again back to the
original topic escape plan escape to
Sylvester Stallone it's not confirmed if
Arnold one returning but they are saying
that salam will be taking more of a
supporting role I don't know what's the
loans doing these days he's just not
leading the movies he's the star of any
more help us please try to help another
person heh yeah that's cool um I thought
escape plan was a major letdown now I
didn't exactly have like major high
hopes for it but why not we could
because it's Arnie and sly is yeah in
their first movie starring together it's
not across from each other it's not
schwarzenegger making a cameo in an
Expendables movie this is then that like
a star and star in one movies together
and the whole time to do if I'm wrong
but that trailer for that movie as I
recall it now which may be very poor but
it seems like the whole trailer is
setting up a situation where they're
talking to each other so that stallone
can go away from our sources like I'm
about to watch a movie about a guy
leaving Arnold Schwarzenegger's prisons
but I want to see those dudes together
doing cool [ __ ] yeah I know yeah that
well the thing that happened in that
movie no we're working together on how
they can both escape okay yeah you got
that totally wrong okay good yeah I
don't remember very well
I'm being honest with you well the thing
with its k plan that really sucked was
you don't get enough of fun Arnie and
slide talking and there's really no
action in the film because they're in
prison the whole time Geiger cut that
now and I'm like when you put Stallone
and are in a film you know they're buff
guys or guns they're not fighters the
grand Stallone can fight but still he's
also Rambo and Cobra like we want to see
them like kicking ass with guns and [ __ ]
and then instead we get them in jail
uniform just trying to figure out to get
off this faceoff like prison like the
one place where you're not gonna get any
of that collection in jail um I so I
would not be interested at all in seen
this k plan to if Carl unless like
what's the point of watching the zoo
Carnales not in the tip here's how it
could work Greg is you take the escape
plan franchise and make it the
expendables but a one-on-one version so
each one has like a different cool
action star and then they make up for
the let down with the first movie and
let them both kick ass together
interesting so make it like a Stallone
featuring Dolph Lundgren this I more
Stallone featuring some other dude you
know Wesley Snipes like lets you do that
does the plot of the set of a Sylvester
Stallone's character an escape plan is
that he kind of goes to prison so he can
escape from them to test out how
reliable these prisons are function
that's like what they get hackers for
now yeah but then he gets put in an
actual prison where he just can't escape
from it Ali the super-advanced reframed
to be in person Billy Crudup here you
know something must be wrong in this jim
caviezel jim caviezel the same guy have
you ever seen in the same room together
before I told you know both place /
mindset a passion of the christ what did
jim caviezel play Superman dr. Mann
basically Superman that was Billy Crudup
yeah the gym can be achieved me to Jesus
it's basically Superman yeah like or no
Jesus technically was the first
superhero if you look at the Bible as a
fictional piece
how you look at it is and it's got some
structural similarities um uh wait
someone asked a question about Norman
street in norman reedus Norman Reedus
point oh yeah who said that who said
that who talked all Curt was talking
Alexander Haws asking about Norman
Reedus playing ghost rider could not
have been a more perfect choice you know
what I haven't talked about this whole
time what Nightwing Nightwing is one of
my all-time favorite comic book
characters John vouch for me on this is
true he's got a whole Nightwing movie
series he's told me about many times so
Nightwing's one of my all-time favorite
comic book characters and I really feel
that that the fact that people are
actually asking for Steven Yeun to be
Nightwing yes huge that's me [ __ ]
incredible that's wicked as an Asian man
myself full-blown korean i'm
half-filipino i hope you know this about
me but I come from Thailand 119th time
when I I'm hearing so much talks about
um you know like I'm Asian American
actors are pretty much getting [ __ ]
over and Hollywood a lot these days but
I feel like Steven Yeun is the first
Asian American actor to really be
hitting the market without having to do
like martial arts or something he was on
the cover of Entertainment Weekly alone
on the cover of Entertainment Weekly who
love Glenn people love Glenn and when
his eyeballs popping out how can you not
love him how can you not feel for that
guy I haven't you seen it i feel flowers
under Alice I just thought you were a
Mexican varies very blunt gotta learn
how to phrase your sentences or he just
meant it that way even Mexico you a
Mexican thought you were mexican oh yeah
so Steven llanes because his night Dick
Grayson him being white is not integral
to the story at all yeah you know it's
not like the Iron Fist of
set that I feel happen where it was like
because I'm like the Danny ran character
is a guy who was white and his own he
gets his whole cultural shock and raised
by Asian people with like the culture
gap was always up yeah that was a part
of that here it's like night Dick
Grayson losses his family when he was
really young he's an orphan and he was
raised by Bruce Wayne why not make him
an asian guy I think that'd be so cool
the season and see when you need to do
any martial arts and maybe I don't know
if he does real life but how cool would
it be if you learned I do martial arts
or this movie yeah you know I don't see
even yell would be a great night wing
I'm totally for it any other actor I
would just feel like no loss of play
Robin yeah yeah Nightwing is like cool
Rob yeah Lou Robin you want to play uh
but get me that take every Walking Dead
actor and make them a notable superhero
cuz Norman Reedus yeah you can play
ghost rider cuz he's basically asked
writer in the logging dead yeah just add
some fire to his head in a little more
he'll there you go I think Andrew
Lincoln would be a great Lex Luthor no
give the guy who played Dale oh oh
tensley William mine mean he said who
should play the next Rambo and that was
actually our next story after escape
plan to their rebooting Rambo without
Sylvester Stallone it's like a soft
reboot they wanted they're saying they
want to continue it like the Bond
franchise they're calling this one Rambo
new blood you know anytime I do this
with a franchise a works out very well
yeah terminator salvation the bourne
legacy this is the thing though is take
them out of take the storms out who
needs them triple lactated that you I
don't want to be that guy but I don't
think that that you can make another
rent it's the same reason why Point
Break doesn't work anymore is because
you need Keanu Reeves you need Gary
Busey you need Loree better you need
those people you need Patrick Swayze
like he is random owes you see Stallone
when you sear it wasn't that long ago
when Stallone played Rambo last and
still was like the most
killer asst MERS Rambo we'd ever seen
yeah and and the thing is to like you
could James Bond any one of these roles
you could take Jason Bourne you could
take Ethan Hunt or you could take Rambo
and you can put somebody else in but the
thing is you have to commit to that in a
way that I don't think studios are
willing to any more like you gotta pay
for a few movies to get that done you
know yeah and I don't think people like
if it's not a hit now people don't
really want to finance that stuff so I
don't I don't I don't want to be that
guy but I don't think you can recast
rambro I just don't think you can do it
I feel like if you suddenly like try
going back to like what first blood was
you know there was a lot of like
commentary on the War and Vietnam like
all had stuff and how soldiers were
treated when they came back to the
states maybe you could explore some of
that with with all the recent terrorist
and war events that we've had in our
country lately maybe but don't call
rabbit yeah it's like a new [ __ ]
movie Allen said yeah we were inspired
by Rambo I would weigh more watch a
movie that gladly emits is inspired by
Rambo instead of saying Rambo new blood
and Stallone not being in it cuz I'm
like why the [ __ ] would I do that well
honestly I feel like that's how this
stuff works and it goes in across all
genres yeah we experience it a lot with
horror is like who can take over this
mantle or how can we reboot this and I
think what a lot of people want is
something that scratches the same itch
without trying to be the exact same
thing so it's exactly like you said if I
always harp on point break but if they
took the point break remake and went ah
extreme sports action caper with a
little ecological spin we make something
that's a tribute we love tributes now a
lot more than we love rehashing so yeah
have you made something that fills the
void Rambo left but is a different
character and made a badass movie with
cool action that has the spirit that's
the way you do it but it's not Rambo you
know I just feel like you can't if
anything call it a different thing and
put rent do what you did with Creed
that's the one way I could see if
possibly working you want Rambo in the
supporting role you give someone else
the title of the movie
and you put a Rambo in there to pass off
the torch in some capacity that's the
only way I could see it but don't call
Rambo but even then yeah it's like even
then you're passing it on to somebody
who's movies will feel different or they
at least should feel different because
if they feel too much like Rambo it's
the uncanny valley and we'll know it's
not Rambo Rambo so like that's the
conundrum of these things so should they
reboot it without so on I don't think so
I just think it would be someone
necessary um hey is our uh Wi-Fi is our
internet still working guys people are
still responding in real time only have
10 people 11 it this is so sad
everyone's watching the flash oh maybe
everyone's watching the flash why is the
flash take away all our views it's like
they put more content now there's stuff
that we do it's almost like to have a
network television network um and okay
our last story that we wanted to talk
about it there's other stories that we
because we cover stories last week the
last one I wanted to talk about was
Christopher Nolan continues to kick ass
and Hollywood yeah dude find the good
fight he's there they're releasing
dunkirk getting an early release in 35
millimeter and 70 millimeter formats on
top of that too when it's actually
release most of the film was shot with
imax 65 millimeter large-format cameras
have you ever seen a no-no director I've
seen plenty of other directors do the
closest a movie came to capturing how
great like the clever usage of IMAX
cameras I felt was hunger games catching
fire rogue nation and I'm rogue nation
ghost Protocol has some pretty cool imax
moments but I feel like Nolan when it
comes to the when it comes to the imax
usage of the cameras he no one does it
better than him no one does it more
fluidly than he does he his transitions
are just brilliant whether he knows
exactly what he even knows when to
use it when there's no action he knows
like what are the right scenes to use
this into at its effect yeah yeah he
seems like I'm he just seems like an
all-around masterful filmmaker the
interstellar i saw in imax and that was
also fantastic was breathtaking and
that's the thing is like even he's one
of those are tours who even if he has
shortcomings here there even if there
are things you know then kind of leave
edges on his movies he's lazy screen
right no no no i don't think he's boys
he's far from late he's a little
romantic maybe but you know like I think
yeah he is sort of a master craftsman
and I always get excited about this
stuff man like like to have you know I
don't think every I'm not one of those
people who thinks that only there should
be film like I like a lot of digital
stuff too we use that technology all the
time but I am really happy to see people
you know preserving film because there
is nothing like and there's something to
be said for that physical media and I'm
always excited for what he does because
not only is it going to be tangible but
it's also gonna look amazing probably
and have a really good story behind it
you know so it's the perfect synthesis
of you know format and form and story
Nolan is probably the greatest marketing
person of all time yeah no one knows
much about dunkirk come it's already
based on a true story that you know you
can look up with the true stories about
but no one knows what this film is gonna
be like all we saw was these
announcements about I was shooting it
that's Christopher Nolan and a cool
teaser trailer where everyone's looking
up at something well then I mean that's
a testament to his power as a filmmaker
because now we hear his name and yeah
we're always look who is the title text
of all his the font of all his final
texts trailer all to say well and
knowing has like the way he advertises
his movies it seems to me like the
effect it has on me is like I feel like
this is a guy who really wants me to see
this and doesn't want to give anything
away that's how his trailers feel to me
um so he's really good at that ow delsey
you're talking about shows I'm gonna be
starting up I'm not really going to be
like covering a lot of shows i like to
keep the shows just for me usually yeah
it just do this kind of like I don't I
don't want to put all
my hobbies out there it's so shows us
like it was like a big episode of the
walking dead i'll talk about it but i'm
planning on doing a video with my
neighbor Tony it's a special kind of
video we're going to be reviewing the
MCU Netflix shows all in one video so
keep a lookout for that edgy veggie just
so you know yeah we did do the life
trailer and it is up has a few hours ago
is there any other news you guys would
like us to talk about if not we're gonna
call it a night join jeff oh yeah johnny
depp and fantastic beasts and where to
find them part two Johnny Depp will be
in that movie I'm excited for that I
like said I feel like that's a great
choice for Johnny Depp I feel like with
all like the big image he hasn't with
knowing the filmmaking the quality of
filmmaking and storytelling that goes
into these films and with JK Rowling
highly involved in this like she's
writing them that's a big big deal and I
feel like Johnny Depp is the perfect
kind of actor to LA you know who I would
like to see in the movies Evan Peters I
feel like he would be great that would
be very cool Suzanne that's the thing is
I am excited to hear that he's gonna do
fantastic beasts and it is because of
that intangible thing for me anyway is
because you know you know that if he's
showing up in samana exist like yeah
it's a big franchise studio movie but at
the same time it seems like the hand
that guides the heart of it is you know
true to the spirit of the books and and
you know it's she wrote that movie the
gay movie so they're making five of
those movies yeah and and that seems
like a tall order to me but at the same
time I I trust the people involved in a
way that like when I hear Johnny Depp
and tim burton are working together
again I'm like I know it's gonna be kind
of big now and I just don't trust the
hand that guides the heart as much as I
do with this so I have my you know
trepidations about it but I think it's
really cool like I'm more excited about
this than not it's a great superstar to
announce to be involved and I'm really
excited to see ya it's not confirmed yet
who is going to be playing people have
their speculation and their theories I
don't know that Harry Potter world
enough to like really
joining on that conversation but you
know Harry Potter enough to know that
like it thrives partly on distinct
characters yeah and when we know Johnny
Depp is good at distinct characters when
he's really there and so you know when
he's with tim burton he does a certain
kind of thing and when he's been pirates
he does a certain kind of thing but i
feel like in the harry potter world that
could bring a color out of him we
haven't seen yeah yeah and and I'm
excited for that most definitely because
I feel like in the in that kind of world
he would know how to I feel like he
would be able to find that good balance
of definite wacky zany kind of cartoony
whimsy alert felled realism they find a
good medium for that you know like
that's what it was great about him in
the first pirates was that or if you
look at it his other weird rolled back
then like Edward Scissorhands or ed wood
or you know bennion his role in Benny
and June like it he was always both
human and character yeah awesome yeah
there's always quirkiness and weirdness
to them and I feel like he's agreed but
perfect actor for that mm-hmm you know I
would love to see him in Gary Oldman
star and movie together that would be so
cool they played multiple personalities
there you go he'll do bad things to you
I'm so creeped out when you do alright
guys we're calling this a night yeah
we're gonna thanks for tuning in glad
you guys chose not to watch the flash
right thank you for participating with
us even though we're participating with
us yeah where you don't mind doing on
facebook cuz we don't have a huge
Facebook following so it's cool that's a
little smaller you guys are the first
when it inevitably gets bigger we will
remember you yeah being there I like you
guys I like you guys too yeah you have a
good night to you like Tommy lanky you
Tommy we had a friend in school named
Tommy once yes go shower clean yourself
Christine you appreciate you being a
woman clencher thank you for being a oh
it's a mellow day for edgy did you
really go take a walk and you go take a
walk the afternoon you can go pick up a
woman at the bar sure your Reggie veggie
not bad not bad sure that's what he
calls himself that all right we're
ending this vibe is a vegetable
or she and is also enjoy tennis off you
hit the button that says finish finish
alright we're finished and I finish
finnish not finnish not finnish yeah i
think what is happening well i won't